I am Mortimer wigglebottom smight Girl
Meets World is one hilarious show but
you know it's even funnier that
gut-busting bloopers brought to you by
the show stars who would have known the
word meatloaf was so funny but there's
just something about the way Payton
Meyer says that specific word that has
everyone including himself in stitches
in the scene Payton's character Lucas is
trying out his fancy British guy accent
with mixed results
it's supposed to sound ridiculous but
his delivery is so outrageous that
everybody around him can't stop laughing
it goes to show that these cast members
aren't just coworkers they're friends
who like to joke around with one another
over the course of Girl Meets World
these actors spend a lot of time
cracking each other up in a way only the
closest of friends can do we don't know
how long this scene took to film but
with everyone having a major case of the
giggles if we wouldn't be surprised if
it took more than a few takes and that's
perfectly fine with us
Lucas is horrendous British accent was a
major highlight from the show and we
would watch this blooper on repeat all
day long this accent will be stuck in
our heads now for days it smells like
you're eating meatloaf
throughout Girl Meets World there have
been some fantastic physical gags that
have left us rolling on the floor in
laughter but what happens when one of
those moments goes haywire that's
exactly what happened to Sabrina
carpenter who plays the lovable and
mischievous Maya Hart on the show she
was asked to jump from rileys bay window
seats to the bed it's clear that Sabrina
was supposed to jump on Riley to get a
better glimpse of the computer but such
a wild stunt proved to be difficult to
pull off we'd be worried about Sabrina
and Rowan's safety in this blooper that
is if both words laughing the entire
time it's apparent that Maya was having
the time of her life doing such an epic
jump and to be honest we would be too
it's also funny how quick Sabrina's to
point the finger at Rowan for screwing
up the jump by moving out of the way
but when someone's jumping full-speed at
you can you really blame them for
reacting that way what would you have
done in that situation being an actor on
television show means you have a lot of
lines to learn but what happens when the
lines written on the page just sound a
little funky that's what happened to
Sabrina in the same scene as before
after she finally makes that long jump
onto the bed she's supposed to read the
dialogue on the computer but when
there's a small snafu it doesn't take
long for both Sabrina and Rowan to break
into giggle fits you can tell Sabrina is
trying her hardest to keep the scene
going though in Sabrina and Rowan are
together we're sure their close
friendship makes it hard to stay serious
already the blooper is hilarious but
what really puts the icing on the cake
is how the script supervisor has to come
over and sort out the blunder it was a
relatively small mistake but it really
makes you think with these actors read
anything that's put on the page in front
of them who knows no matter what though
we imagine future scripts went through a
much more rigorous spellcheck we can't
imagine how hard it must have been to
keep a straight face on the set of Girl
Meets World we obviously think the show
is packed to the brim with hilarious
moments whatever this is do not put me
in the middle of the two people that I
love equally just kidding come here
but how did the actors keep a straight
face most of the time well you could
chalk it up to experience after all some
of the older actors on the show have
been acting since they were kids
chills what can I say it's a gift
although experience didn't really stop
Ben savage from breaking out into
laughter and one of the show's funniest
moments there's a scene where Farkle has
to climb over Cory while they're
standing at the front of the class and
although Ben does his best to stay in
character the wild Farkle flails around
too much and stops pin from saying this
lines out of all the people it's fun to
see Britt character and laugh we have to
say watching Ben goof around is our
favorite to be honest we don't see how
anyone could get through that scene in
character given what's happening so
kudos to him for trying to keep it going
sometimes all it takes is a simple
extended stare to cause a cast member of
Girl Meets World to break character do
you have a close friend you can look at
and share a laugh with no matter what
that seems to be the case but
Queen Rowan and Sabrina as they do have
such a great chemistry on and off the
set it's created a particularly funny
blooper from The Girl Meets yearbook
episode where Riley tries to show off a
darker personality to mix results in the
episode Riley starts acting strangely
and not quite like her usual bubbly self
after an alarming incident regarding the
yearbook she starts going by Moreau Tia
in black and she tries to stay super
serious all the time but we all know
Rowan likes to laugh and in a scene
where she's talking to Sabrina keep it
spot should have an awesome a simple
stare between the two actors forces
Rowan to break from her serious
demeanour it looks like the two are
getting into a staring competition to
see who would laugh first
and of course Rowan starts to laugh
first for the newer cast members on the
show it must be a special honor to make
some of the old guard laugh after all
the original cast members from Boy Meets
World are particularly royalty at this
point Riley I've already met the world
it's your turn
that's why it's always fun to see people
like Ben savage and Ryder strong bright
character and laugh together it's even
better when it's so surprising and comes
out of nowhere in this bloopers Shawn is
supposed to toss his keys to Maya simple
enough right but what starts out as a
simple movement soon turns crazy after
Sabrina has trouble making the catch not
only does she miss the keys being thrown
at her but she soon winds up on the
ground how did that happen but we really
love about this blooper is seeing Ben
turn around to see Sabrina on the floor
completely confused on what just
occurred behind him that's okay Sabrina
you give us all a thumbs up at the end
to show us that you're okay but maybe
next time work a little on your hand-eye
coordination
not all bloopers happen while filming
the show there are a ton of instances of
the cast of girl meets world making
flubs and errors behind the scene - it
shows that they're all just regular
teenagers like the rest of us one of our
favorite behind the scenes bloopers is
an attempt at a Disney shout out where
Peyton Rowan and Amir are asked to show
some love for someone named Allie should
be simple enough right but when they get
the go-ahead that the camera is rolling
it's clear the three of them don't quite
know what to say they're all a little
awkward but it's charming and how these
actors make each other laugh it's
especially hilarious when Peyton tries
to say hello in a weird way which
quickly makes Rowan not only laugh super
hard but also tease him a little about
it directly afterwards we don't know
what's better for Allie getting a super
serious shout out by these three cast
members or having the three of them mess
up and laugh with one another let's be
honest if you had the name Taylor
Tristan cool cool poopy pants mix
stupid-head you might have a hard time
remembering your name - it's not exactly
a name that rolls off the tongue easily
so it's understandable that Peyton had
trouble remembering the exact line
we're amazed he got as close as he did
with all those words in there I'm Taylor
Tristan cool but sorry Peyton cool cool
but poopy pants is a lot different from
cool cool poopy pants mixed stupid-head
in the episode girl meets Holly world a
lot of characters try out for a very
special acting gig with mixed results
the episode is super funny but knowing
how much trouble Peyton had near the end
of the episode saying the complete name
makes it even better the funniest part
is how peyton has to be told by an
outside crew member that he got the name
wrong much to his own frustration it's
okay Peyton the more frustrated you look
trying to get the line the funnier it
becomes we would watch Peyton saying the
name on Lube for hours someone please
make a gif of that please you can tell
the younger cast members of Girl Meets
World are huge fans of the original Boy
Meets World show their knowledge and
memory of the show's extent
history is quite impressive and being
the lead character you would expect
Rowan to know the most about Boy Meets
World
she's topanga's daughter after all for
the most part that's true as you can see
in the behind the scenes quiz that Rowan
knows a lot of fun facts and trivia that
would stump a lot of ordinary people the
one question looks like it completely
fools her for a second and it's one she
should probably know when she's asked
what her father's name is Rowan freezes
for a second as she struggles to answer
court court I know this one I promise
thankfully after some time she's able to
get the correct answer and thank
goodness for that if she had forgotten
her father's own full name she probably
would have been grounded for a week all
it took was thinking about it for a
little while before it clicked and we
have to give props to Rowan for
remembering the answer Cornelius
Cornelius Matthews from all the behind
the scenes videos and blooper reels one
thing that's super clear is how much
this cast enjoyed hanging out with each
other they truly became a family and
when you become that close with your
family it's only natural to start
messing with each other in unique ways
that's what happens between Peyton and
Sabrina as they both talked about how
behind the scenes they got into a little
prank war with each other who ended up
winning I think she won so what was the
best prank Sabrina pulled on Peyton
there was one time when Sabrina
broadcast Peyton's first audition video
to the live studio audience much to
Payton's embarrassment we have to admit
that's a pretty good prank we don't
think anything could top that so major
props to Sabrina for putting that
together we only wish we were in the
audience at the time to see such an epic
moment so that's a wrap on the best
bloopers from Girl Meets World we crack
up every time we hear Peyton say how
about you which one was your favorite
let us know in the comments below and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more hilarious videos like
this thanks for watching
you